Was it the right choice?
[MUSIC] It's
too short to think about such things It's the
last school event I
won't waste it There are
many couples I know who form during these three days
There was something I wanted to do before the school festival, and it
was just that Mr. Uesugi recognized me. I feel like everything will pay off.  I
wish we could stay in this relationship,
but I
feel like I have to find an answer, so
when everything is over today, we'll be
holding our own thoughts
[music]
Waiting for you
So
Fuutarou  He's a special person to me, so I
don't remember giving you permission to enter the room He's here,
even though it means nothing, but I
can't give up I might not be able to come to the school festival anymore, so
listen to the answer now  I wonder if
they can't do it. They were always throwing everything in.
Now it's
my turn.